hello and welcome to this video playing
sv mihailov now ten will s 10 wins 0
losses two drawers i think it seems I
have to have this guy's number ok got a
bogo decent opening a I have some vague
ideas it's not like I'm a universal
expert on this opening I mean I've
written this book but I only covered one
particular line so I don't know each and
every possibility and to this kind of
thing for example I never um studied he
is definitely ok yeah in this position
so maybe 95 so that I can and take on g6
yeah this is interesting guess I had to
take with this
poor context comes into consideration
actually I think I'll do that it's a bit
more interesting to try to get c4 c4
Quincy six maybe okay castles maybe b5
and okay then i go a four maybe five
more difficult to play is still plays it
well it's a very young ambitious move
okay I'll just an adjust castle I
thought that would leave some weaknesses
on the queenside behind so probably
double behind the pawn yeah but this is
quite nice for white I still have the
better structure here I think he has to
play has to prevent a five and go rugae
five yes that was necessary and now
maybe I need some I need some loot for
the king and go from there yes Rukia
maybe
Oh interesting didn't expect that
doesn't mean it is bad or anything I
just didn't see that idea um okay okay
it's hard to not take actually Jim Queen
c3s maybe just happening or this one
yeah it should be possible yeah this is
the problem it really is a problem but
ok I can maybe try to try to play this
to my it sits at all but you never know
check
just Ruby 3 a 3 is a draw this is not a
draw he is he is struggling quite
strange that he allowed this and so
let's go up so II forearm hmm now can
also try to somehow invade on the Kings
side I don't think that this leads to
anything so could we form
hmm bit surprising
Kingda three king is six go up to d3
goes to you five I know maybe I can
zoosk login me there
let's wait for just a moment here and
see maybe h4 actually an h4 cannot he
cannot play king before and take if I
that king and porn ending should be lost
maybe King be no doesn't work yeah I
don't know let's let him fry the movie 5
now I actually wanted to yes he gets
time for against e5 and this this was a
bit of a bit of a shame here if he 5
King be five doesn't work maybe he's six
I can take what the rook okay I'm taking
taking too long him try to try to be
somehow cunning and descending where to
go where where do you go now
sf4 don't really see any other move
don't think giving ground can help okay
28 seconds this is of course a problem
okay it's taking time and self it could
be a draw of course it is it wrong just
g3 drew but ok this is also drawing I
guess that is a probably somewhat fair
result and it's directly him cry so did
I miss a win here why not I actually
forgot that I wanted to take with the
rook I actually I saw this yeah if he
goes here I can keep everything might
there be a draw but it's this is a
better try if he does that this is
probably winning but check this this
here we're also roped you five so here
here and now this probably King here can
be five it's also draw yeah so he can
keep the draw I guess with f4 maybe I
had something better early of it I
couldn't really figure it out I have
like its blackest very much on the ropes
and this ending here also going the
other way and could could be could be
that this was bad
maybe maybe yeah it was it was a very
real decision by black to play look to
be too instead rugby three draws very
easily and after this it's it's a very
close call I mean I was actually
thinking why it should win here maybe
this is also better nobody okay he's got
King g6 dad is probably drawers going
this way that was probably a tougher
test even though in the game I got I got
very close to win I mean absolutely at
first i thought 'i five is good and then
it's six but you can take with the rook
because of this idea only 5 D 5 10 I
don't know I can keep the tension but I
don't see how I'm progressing here
you probably can hold it okay thanks for
watching